à nouveau 10 ans exactement après sa
prise du pouvoir le Parlement chinois
lui confirme un troisième mandat de 5
ans la Constitution lui permettrait même
de rester président à vie
dix années au cours desquelles il a
changé la Chine comme personne ne
l'aurait cru et encore moins voulu de
cet enfant issu de l'élite politique
persécuté sous Mao the Dong on aurait
espéré une continuité dans une certaine
ouverture économique et démocratique sur
le monde au contraire il a accumulé tous
les pouvoirs et même plus que celui
qu'il a réhabilité le Grand Timonier
cette semaine dans les photos qu'on voit
du Président si Jean Ping on le voit
habillé à nouveau en habit Mao en habit
classique de l'époque mais si jumping a
décidé de reprendre l'image de Mao parce
qu'en fait dans les faits il a récupéré
tous les pouvoirs que Mao avait à
l'époque la direction du parti la
présidence du pays ce que Maul n'avait
même pas et surtout aussi la présidence
de la commission militaire du parti on
dit de sidgine que c'est le président de
tout tellement il a des pouvoirs énormes
en plus de s'être entouré au sein du
parti et au sein maintenant un nouveau
gouvernement qui est élu cette semaine
toute une équipe d'idéologues qui
partagent complètement ses idées sa
vision de la renaissance de la Chine
pour en faire la première superpuissance
du monde passe par une armée encore plus
puissante et le renforcement des
secteurs de haute technologie touchées
par les sanctions occidentales qui va
s'en occuper le Parti communiste chinois
qui va prendre en main cette partie de
l'économie et de la finance réservée
jusqu'ici au secteur privé et ça c'est
extrêmement important parce que
l'économie chinoise la dynamisme de
l'économie chinoise contrairement à tout
ce qu'on peut penser à l'extérieur de la
Chine le dynamisme de de l'économie
chinoise vient d'un secteur privé qui
correspond à peu près à 70% de
l'économie et qui fonctionnait bien tant
que le parti le laissait fonctionner le
problème qui s'en vient c'est que
l'obsession de pouvoir de site Jinping
va pousser le Parti communiste à
s'infiltrer de ou de force dans le
secteur privé aussi qu'est-ce que ça va
donner surtout dans le contexte d'une
économie chinoise affaiblie entre autres
par la politique désastreuse de la zéro
covid la spectaculaire volte-face siging
ne lui a pas visiblement fait perdre la
face ce qui est intolérable en Chine
mais il y a faute et elle s'ajoute à des
attitudes agressives envers l'Occident
et un certain soutien à Vladimir Poutine
et sa guerre en Ukraine mal vu par ses
plus grands clients l'Europe et les
États-Unis la situation de seigin ping
n'est peut-être pas aussi solide qu'elle
en a l'air cette âme là est arrivée il a
établi un pouvoir absolu par la force
par des purges politiques importantes
par des purges au nom de la corruption
le danger c'est qu'il s'est créé des
ennemis dans ce parti-là et c'est pas
nouveau dans l'histoire de la Chine
qu'un pouvoir absolu soit renversé par
une opposition et il y a une opposition
en Chine parce que malgré le fait qu'il
occupe une sorte de pouvoir absolu si
Jane pin craint beaucoup la population
et l'impatience surtout de la classe
moyenne chinoise qui est très importante
cette Chine encore un peu plus
impénétrable n'a pas fini de nous
étonner
Jean-Michel Leprince a du Canada
Montréal
[Applaudissements]